when this happened to you you're 35
years old right you're a grown man i
know you like the joke i'm an old man i
mean you're literally your prime bro
right um when that happened to him he
was 23 years old correct right this was
five years ago i think he's 27 now 22
whatever
you've had a lot more life experiences
and been in fights literally
proverbially all that versus someone
who's 23
i can see where you're coming from being
like he's been groomed by this
by this virtual governments these
digital media companies he needs them
and you're right he was younger at the
time i would like to think that patrick
has been through a much harder situation
in his life at younger than 23 than
cancellation and wasn't crying his eyes
out like a little girl so the dude's
obviously emotionally soft he needs them
and the reason he needs them is because
logan paul doesn't have fancy as viewers
and that's what's actually been
highlighted to me significantly since my
banning that there's a massive
difference between those two things
logan paul is a person who needs the
platforms and needs the algorithms and
people will watch him but they will sit
there and most of them will call him
names but he will have views that is
different than having fans when you have
fans if you look at me for example when
i got canceled they say where's tate
where is he i'll go anywhere he is i'll
download any app i'll uninstall the
other apps i'll take his content and
post it on the platforms they don't want
him on where is tate that's a fan and
that's different when you only have
viewers you need the algo i don't need
the outro as long as people know where i
am they're gonna come and it's a
completely different scenario who's
whose playbook you think he's following
if you were to say because isn't that
the hollywood playbook like you follow
that playbook and as long as you because
that's what you're speculating he's
following the playbook of you follow our
narrative we're going to give you the
world i think that since the dawn of
human time
anybody who had power understood that it
was a particular demographic which is
going to become dangerous to their power
neck mechanism in the future
it's it's not a new idea
the idea that the romans would conquer a
greek city and kill all the kill all the
boys and all the military age males it's
always been the same right who's going
to cause us trouble if we want to hold
this city these guys will get rid of
them so nowadays i think what they're
trying to do is neuter this class
they're trying to neutral this class by
affecting them mentally and affecting
their mindset and affecting their
ability to think critically and if you
neuter this class you're far less likely
to have a revolution when you do
something crazy like i don't know like
for example imagine for two and a half
years you want to lock everyone in their
houses because of the common cold let's
imagine you're going to do something
tyrannical you would want to ensure that
this class of individuals were so busy
concerned with either being depressed or
jerking off or being physically weak or
or distracted so they didn't all stand
up and go wait
this common cold can't hurt me and i and
i just started my business and i ain't
going bankrupt for this [ __ ]
they don't want that so they're trying
to neuter a certain class of people
i don't really want to talk too much in
depth about who i think they are because
i'm trying to stay alive and i would
never kill myself but it's certainly
happening i think anybody with a brain
can see the narrative is out there and
the narrative is being reported and
accelerated by all mainstream media
channels and people who are allowed to
have a platform such as logan paul have
sold their soul cut their dicks off and
they sat there and say yes i will say
what you tell me to say please don't
cancel me i am a fearful individual the
dude is a punk if ever meets me in the
cage i will destroy him in real time for
free and he knows that
what about the brother
well jason at least well this is the
interesting thing about those two right
because
me and my brother have become the most
famous brothers on the planet so
there's also a degree of jealousy
involved i was just gonna ask that you
get the tate rose
and the paul brothers and it's like this
balance of power that's being shifted
and this
completely sort of this dance that's
happening it's interesting right because
you had the disney brothers
the disney brothers who gained a bunch
of power and notoriety and they were the
most famous brothers on the planet and
they've now been usurped by my brother
and i who come from a very unfortunate
background girl from the street did
everything ourselves and obviously
the youth of the world today have an
affinity and feel a synergy with us they
don't feel with the disney brothers
because the disney brothers had a very
easy privileged life you know they grew
up relatively easily in privilege if you
get disney contract then you become a
youtuber you've never really no struggle
i mean you've had it pretty good so
there's a degree of jealousy involved
jake at least stood up for free speech
uh jake has said some negative comments
about me i've said a few negative things
about him but i have nothing personal
against jake and also i find it
interesting that jake and logan are not
even that close they may pretend to be
obviously their brothers but jake and
ksi have beef they're literally trying
to hurt each other logan is ksi's best
friend when you ask logan who would he
choose between ksi and and his brother
in a boxing match he's like oh i don't
know man you can't even choose his own
flesh and blood over some [ __ ] dude
he met it's their whole relationship is
weird if you insult my brother or you
have any kind of problem with my brother
you have a problem with me that's
on-site permanent like me and my brother
are like this but they're not like that
they have this weird relationship and
they slept with each other's girlfriends
and a bunch of weird [ __ ] so i don't
know what's going on with them if you
enjoyed this video and you want to watch
the entire podcast click over here and
if you want to be connected with experts
influencers such as kiyosaki tate
connolly parliamentary myself and others
download the app minect where you get a
chance to connect with these folks by
the minute you get to buy the minute or
have face times with them 15 minutes ask
them any questions you may want to have
download the app connect and start
connecting with influencers and experts
today